- Let's say hello to Mikey Day, everybody.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
- Sweet, I like your outfit.
- Thank you, you too.
- Yeah, nice threads.
Okay, so you've been here-
- You have me on with an icon,
telling awesome Elvis stories.
- I know, what are you
bringing to the table, Mikey?
- Nothing. Nothing.
- No, I have to ask this though,
'cause I'm new to the building.
I love working here.
- It's awesome.
- You, yeah.
- Welcome.
- Yes, so do you love it?
Do you have like your favorite places?
- Yeah, it's fun seeing NBC
like, news casters in the lobby.
I've seen Lester Holt, just
walking in jeans, which is-
- [Kelly] Which trips you out.
- You're like, "you don't own jeans."
(audience and guests laugh)
You were born in a suit.
So, Rachel Maddow, I've seen.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- At the Starbucks.
- Down below.
- I know that
Starbucks, the subway Starbucks.
- Right, the subway Starbucks.
- Have you ever been in
there like, really early?
I had a early call time,
it was like 6 something AM.
They were blasting music, I was like-
- Oh really?
- Like, it was like a rave.
(audience and guests laughing)
- And you were like-
- I looked at these two and
I was like, "It's 6 AM, bro."
I was like, that's early.
- But, was it Kelly Clarkson music?
- No, not even my music.
- Then I'm not going, it's
your music or nothing.
Your music or nothing!
- It was actually good.
♪ Some people wait a lifetime ♪
♪ For a moment like this ♪
(audience cheers)
- You know what? It would've
been more acceptable at 6 AM.
- I watched that and almost cried.
- Oh, I did cry.
- Well, I was like, "Kelly
deserves it so much."
(audience and Kelly laughing)
"Kelly is a star."
- Thank you!
- I was, I remember I was in college.
- I was just telling her
the first season of "Idol,"
they have a person every week, too
and ours was Burt Bacharach.
- [Mikey] Oh, really?
- That came on that week.
Yeah, and we did Burt Bacharach songs.
I did "Walk On By", before Doja.
- Before Doja. Before Doja.
- That's right.
- Because, I don't know if she was alive.
I'm a lot older than her.
(audience and guests laugh)
So wait, I've been on SNL
and I will say the most
upsetting thing for me to watch
is, I'm there all day, right?
Even as a musical guest,
you're there all day, right?
- [Mikey] Right.
- And you watch all these skits get cut.
- [Mikey] Oh yeah.
- So, like what, and I
mean and like funny ones!
Like, sometimes y'all will
keep some, and I'm like,
"Why did you keep that one over that one?"
I'm like, "I liked that one."
- That always happens.
"Why did you cut that?"
- Yeah, so has a great one
that you loved ever been cut?
- I mean, yeah, a lot of
stuff's been cut over the years.
Sometimes you'll put one
up at the table read,
where they choose what'll
go to dress rehearsal
that never get picked.
It was around Christmas
time when we wrote,
this was years back,
when Trump was still
president at the time.
(guest groans)
And it was- (laughs)
(audience and Kelly laughing)
I was hesitant to even bring it up.
(audience cheering)
(guests clapping)
I just heard. I heard-
- Like it was just a sound.
- I heard a sound, I'm like,
yep, I know, I know exactly.
- [Kelly] It was just sound, from the gut.
- But it was, that's so funny.
(Kelly laughing)
I just heard it, I'm like,
"Why did I even bring it up?"
- So wait, so that's happening.
- Yeah, it was-
- So there's a lot of material
there though, for SNL.
- Yeah, it was a "Home Alone"
and Eric Trump was left
home alone in Trump Tower.
(audience and Kelly laugh)
And so, Don Jr. had to go back.
and, "I gotta get back to
New York, Eric's home alone."
and there were like
investigators coming in,
in place of the burglars.
- How did this get cut?
- I know, well it didn't even get picked
so it didn't even make it to the place
where it could be cut, but all
of Eric's traps didn't work.
He was like hosing down the carpet
and we were a little bummed,
'cause you know, obviously
"Home Alone" is a classic, so.
- It is a classic.
- But you know, there's,
every week, there's stuff.
- I know, I just noticed, I
was like, man, they get rid
of some funny stuff sometimes.
- Yeah, you gotta come host.
- [Kelly] Oh my god.
- You'd be fantastic and do music.
(audience cheering)
(Mikey clapping)
- Here's the thing, I don't
think I'm funny like that.
- You'd be awesome.
- Like I can be witty at times,
like just talking.
- [Mikey] You'd be awesome.
- But, I don't think I'm funny like that.
I did do a couple skits one time though,
when I went to sing there.
It was with Horatio.
- Oh, okay.
- What's hard for me is, I laugh.
- [Mikey] That's fine.
- Like y'all, no it's not.
(Mikey laughs)
No it's not, you're supposed to act,
you're supposed to like stay in character.
But like, yeah. I don't know
how any of y'all held it down.
I don't know if y'all saw Pedro Pascal,
when he was in the hospital
and (mimics nasal voice)
- [Mikey] Oh my God.
- I was like-
- He was awesome.
- I peed my pants, watching that.
Like, how did you all not,
and you're all looking at
him like (mimics nasal voice)
and I was like, how are
they not laughing right now?
- I mean, sometimes there will be sketches
and the camera will be on you
and then you'll try to keep it together
and then when the
camera's on someone else,
you'll start laughing, like especially-
- And then you screw them.
- I know, but someone like Pedro,
who was so good.
- [Kelly] Yeah, oh my God.
It's so funny.
- But I think
you would be fantastic.
- You are very nice.
- [Mikey] I mean it.
(audience cheering)
Well, it's time for another
commercial break, everybody.
Saturday Night Live returns this weekend.
You can watch on NBC and Peacock.
We've got a touching story.
(audience members laughing)